Heute im Rasenfunk?
Alexander Schur! Das ist ein Mädchen, ein unglaubliches Mädchen. Der Frankfurter schießt Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga.
Langhaar fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Schluss vorbei aus, der S ist vor allem das A- und P-Team steht für attraktiv und preiswert in der Bundesliga. Und jetzt ist das letzte Kapitel im verrücktesten Fußballmärchen der Saison geschrieben.
Der Blick auf andere Jungs Ja, das hättet ihr nicht gedacht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass hier erst der Aufstieg von Eintracht Frankfurt kommt, dann der vom FC Augsburg und dann der vom SSV Ulm. 1848, 46, ohje, da geht's schon los. Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr. Es ist eine Weile her und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier in der Rasenfunk Ligatur, dem Format, in dem der Moderator immer perfekt vorbereitet ist. Die Mannschaften, die wir gerade gehört haben, die haben alle das geschafft, was die Teams, über die wir jetzt sprechen, auch gerne mal schaffen würden. Ein Aufstieg aus der 2. in die 1. Liga. Manchen war das schon mal vergönnt, aber aktuell sind sie alle Zweitligisten und damit haben alle Füchselinnen und Füchse unter euch schon herausgefunden. Wir sprechen heute über die 2. Liga der Männer und ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und ich freue mich sehr, hier eine fantastische Runde begrüßen zu dürfen. Zum einen ist hier Anna Lautenbach. Ihr kennt sie natürlich unter anderem auch vom Podcast Gegengerade von 210. Da ist sie auch immer wieder zu hören. Wir hatten sie auch hier zu Eintracht Braunschweig schon zu Gast. Hallo Anna, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Es ist wirklich, ich bin so gehypt. Das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen. Das liegt nicht nur an dem Kaffee, den ich mir jetzt noch zu dieser Uhrzeit reingepfeffert habe. Unter anderem liegt das auch daran, dass wir Susanne Vetter hier haben. Sie ist Ressortleiterin Sport bei der neuen Osnabrücker Zeitung. Sie ist außerdem zu hören im sehr empfehlenswerten Osnabrück Podcast Brückengeflüster. Hallo Susanne, schön, dass du mal im Rasenfunk bist.
Ja, hallo Max. Ich freue mich auch, dass ich mal zu Gast sein darf bei euch.
Ja, ist doch klar. Ist ja auch schon seit Ewigkeiten auf unserer Pod-Roll. Das ist für mich inzwischen der erste Anlaufpunkt, wenn ich eigene Gäste suche. Mal gucken, welche Podcasts gibt es denn da. Also schön, dass du hier bist und schön, dass auch zum elften Mal hier Grüße an Andreas Thies, Tobias Rieger hier ist von der Sport-BG mit Andreas und Tobi Weitz, ein kleiner Insider, aber das halten wir alle aus. Schön, Tobi, dass du mal wieder da bist. Du sprichst natürlich über Hannover 96.
Ein Insider, den du mir vorweggenommen hast, den ich natürlich jetzt auch wollte, einfließen lassen. Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Da siehst du, diese Hinterhältigkeit hätte ich dir gar nicht zugetraut. Bei mir war ich mehr dessen bewusst. Aber gut, so ist das eben. Wir wollen reden über die 2. Liga-10-Spiel-Tage, sind da absolviert. Bevor wir starten, aber noch der Hinweis, diese Sendung hier, wie alle anderen im Rasenfunk, ist werbepaywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir sind allein crowdfinanziert. Auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Auch kleine Beträge helfen. Es funktioniert hier alles nach dem Value for Value Prinzip. Also ihr entscheidet einfach, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, welchen Wert haben die Sendung, die wir für euch machen. Und den überweist ihr uns dann. Und dann kann ich da von meinem Lebensunterhalt bestreiten und unsere Gäste bekommen. Ein Honorar und der Rasenfunk kann wachsen. Nächstes Ziel würde ich sagen, regelmäßiger noch folgen, wie diese hier machen. Da brauchen wir aber dann noch mehr Moderatoren. Also irgendwann kriege ich das alleine nicht mehr gestemmt. rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club. Danke für alle, die uns unterstützen und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de könntet ihr uns auch den Merch-Shop leerkaufen, wenn ihr denn wolltet. Jetzt wollen wir aber über die 2. Liga sprechen. Es war ein interessanter Spieltag, finde ich. Viel, viel ist passiert. Lasst mal, bevor wir über eure Vereine sprechen, ganz allgemein beginnen. Anna, wie hat dir denn der Spieltag gefallen? Was fandest du besonders bemerkenswert?
Der Spieltag hat mir sehr gut gefallen, denn ich war in Griechenland und habe… Ja, tatsächlich. Hatte das Schlimmste auch schon hinter mir. Nachdem wir ja Freitag Abend gespielt hatten, konnte ich mich dann entspannen. Ja, also ich glaube, was uns allen am ehesten im Gedächtnis geblieben ist, zumindest mir tatsächlich, ist dieses unfassbare Spiel in Düsseldorf, was stellvertretend dafür ist, dass der Abstiegskampf krass spannend ist. Aber der Abstiegskampf ist tatsächlich noch spannender, wenn man denn davon sprechen möchte. Denn mir ist völlig klar, zu welchem Zeitpunkt der Saison wir uns hier zusammenfinden. Es ist ja noch sehr, sehr früh. Die Hälfte der Hinrunde ist schon gespielt. Ich meine aber trotzdem, dass man erste Tendenzen absehen kann, wer da oben mitmischt und wer nicht. Und da freue ich mich extrem drauf. Ich habe trotz der widrigen Situation des eigenen Vereins heftig Bock auf die Zweite-Liga-Saison. Und unter anderem die Fortuna, aber auch Kaiserslautern leider auch ein Verein, den wir –ja, genau –sorgen dafür, dass es sehr spannend ist. Tatsächlich auch nicht zuletzt meine eigene Eitelkeit sehr zufrieden stellt, weil ich vor der Saison gesagt habe, wenn der FC St. Pauli da anknüpft, wo er aufgehört hat, im Frühjahr und Frühsommer wird er eine relevante Rolle da oben spielen. Und das tut er. Und ich finde das nicht nur spannend, sondern steht auch tatsächlich für nicht nur unterhaltsam, sondern teilweise auch wirklich sehr gut im Fußball. Und das hat man am letzten Spieltag repräsentativ doll gesehen.
Also einmal war das ein 4 zu 3 von Fortuno Düsseldorf gegen Kaiserslautern. Für alle, die die Ergebnisse nicht parat haben. Nach 0 zu 3 Rückstand im ersten Freikartenspiel, dann eben noch 4 zu 3 gewonnen. Und das andere war das 2 zu 2 von St. Pauli bei Paderborn. Da ging es auch fröhlich hin und her. Ich habe Tobi jetzt schon mehrmals zucken sehen, als es um Aufstiegskampf ging. Ich habe auch irgendwie das Gefühl, dass da eine gewisse Nervosität hier im Raum war, in unserem digitalen Raum. Tobi, ist das das einzige Thema, das dich wahrscheinlich gerade beschäftigt mit Blick auf die Liga?
Natürlich. Es geht nur um den Aufstiegskampf. Alles andere ist in Hannover noch nie Thema gewesen. Nein. Nein, wenn du grundsätzlich nach dem Spieltag fragst, muss ich natürlich sagen, besser kannst du nicht reinstarten. 18.30 Uhr, Freitag, 2-1 gewonnen, drei Punkte im Sack. Was dann parallel in Elbersberg passiert ist, Anna hat es gerade angesprochen, hat natürlich auch durchaus die Stimmung gehoben. Deshalb war das einer der Spieltage, die ich deutlich mehr genossen habe als so manch andern. Wenn Anna gerade den Blick nach oben geworfen hat, mache ich vielleicht den Blick nach unten, einfach damit wir so ein bisschen gegenseitig sind. Es ist jetzt nichts, was mich groß begeistert hätte, aber doch arg schockiert, das was da auf Schalke passiert ist. Oder mit Schalke in Karlsruhe. Schalke ist unser nächster Gegner am nächsten Wochenende. Die verlieren einfach 3 zu 0 nach dem Trainerwechsel. Das war schon etwas, was bei mir in diesem Spieltag irgendwie hängen geblieben ist.
Ja, da sind wir jetzt dann auch direkt im Keller über den, werden wir heute auch noch ein bisschen sprechen. Susanne, was waren für dich noch so Momente dieses Spieltags?
Ja, genau, ich wusste ja, dass die Frage kommt. Du hast es angedeutet und ich habe mir zwei Sachen aufgeschrieben, tatsächlich mal vorher noch mal, die ich vielleicht nennen wollte. Das war es 4 zu 3 von Vorduna Düsseldorf. Aber natürlich auch deswegen, weil ich schaue immer nach Düsseldorf, ist ja klar, da ist Daniel Tunetrainer, der war lange ein Osnabrück-Aufstiegstrainer, hier hat er auch gespielt. Und ja, das war schon ein besonderes Verhältnis auch zu ihm als Trainer, muss man auch sagen, weil er hier ja dann quasi seine erste Station hatte. Und ja, wir den Weg immer mitbegleitet haben jetzt. Und deswegen gucke ich da natürlich auf jeden Fall immer drauf. Und ja, das 0-3 von Schalke muss ich auch sagen, das hat mich halt auch wirklich überrascht. Aber für ein VfL Osnabrück ist es auch gar nicht so schlecht, dass da unten noch ein paar Mannschaften sind, die zumindest so in Reichweite sind. Wobei ich nicht unbedingt glaube, dass Schalke die Arminia macht vom letzten Jahr. Und ja, ich bin noch ein bisschen skeptisch. Aber dann als Frenkin natürlich, 1. FC Nürnberg gegen Hertha WSC, jawoll.
Wann kommt denn hier die Hertha-Niederlage endlich mal zur Straße?
Ja, das hat mir natürlich ganz besonders gut geschmeckt.
Das glaube ich. Der Club auf Platz 9 damit gesprungen und die Hertha kurzfristig überholt. Also da war so einiges zu holen. Kiel auch noch in Rostock fand ich einfach von der Konstellation her noch eine interessante Passi. Liegt das daran, dass ich so gehyped bin, weil ich mich immer so freue auf diese Ligatour-Sendung? Oder ist es gerade eine besonders gute und unterhaltsame Saison? Ich glaube, Tobi, du bist ja am längsten von allen mit dabei in der 2. Liga.
Ja, das dürfte stimmen. Und ich finde tatsächlich, es ist eine wirklich richtig gute Saison. Es ist unabhängig von Hannover 96. Sonst hatte man irgendwie immer ein, zwei Mannschaften, wo klar war damals, als Bremen da unten war, Schalke, erster Anlauf und solche Geschichten. Da war klar, die steigen wieder auf und dann gucken wir mal, wer zweiter mit ein bisschen Glück oder wer dritter wird. Dieses Jahr, es ist komplett offen. Auch wenn die eine oder der andere vielleicht ins Orakel geguckt hat vor der Saison und gesagt hat, ja, St. Pauli könnte oben mitspielen. Es gab dann ganz viele, die gesagt haben, Paderborn ist, hat sich ja nochmal verstärkt und die sind auch so richtig gut. Und am Ende, ja, es ist gar nicht so ganz überraschend, wer da oben vielleicht unter den ersten sechs, sieben, acht Mannschaften ist. Elversberg vielleicht mal ausgenommen. Aber alles in allem ist es ja auch so eng beieinander, dass du mit einem Sieg oder mit zweimal nicht gewonnen sofort so viele Plätze nach oben oder nach unten verschiebst, dass dann auch alles wieder neu ist. Das ist natürlich normal in den ersten Spieltagen. Aber ich finde, die zweite Liga dieses Jahr, die bietet viel.
Die Frage, die sich mir stellt, ist tatsächlich, ist es überraschend, wo Schalke steht oder nicht? Ich bin so ganz ambivalent, weil ich Teile Tobis Gefühl des beständigen Schocks auf der einen Seite und kann nicht gleichzeitig eines gewissen Schulterzuckens entziehen. Das finde ich schon phänomenal, glaube ich, in der Summe, was da passiert. Also dieser Absturz und auch, ich hatte das Spiel gesehen, zumindest in der Konferenz. Also, weiß ich nicht genau, ob man den neuen Trainer noch nicht sieht oder ob er noch Zeit braucht.
Also jetzt wollen wir nicht den neuen Trainer schon nach einem Spiel ausmachen. Nein, nein. Denk doch mal an die Abfindung.
Sowieso keine Aktien in Schalker Trainer. Nichtsdestotrotz irgendwie spannend, weil es ja nicht so selten ist, dass der Absteiger dann direkt unten mitspielt.
Hertha ist doch auch so angefangen. Die haben ja richtig schlecht den Saisonstart hingelegt. Und die haben sie jetzt inzwischen gefangen. Das heißt, bei Schalke wartet eigentlich jeder drauf. Wann wird es besser? Und es ist Woche für Woche. Wann wird es besser? Jetzt haben sie einen Trainer gewählt. Jetzt wird es besser. Nächsten Samstag spielen sie gegen 6.0. Dann wird es auf jeden Fall besser. Also ich hoffe, sie warten noch eine Woche und danach können sie richtig Gas geben. Dann ist mir alles egal.
Ich erinnere immer an Bielefeld letzte Saison. Da haben auch immer alle gedacht, ja, das wird schon und die kommen da schon noch hoch. Die Bielefelder selbst waren auch richtig ruhig eigentlich eine ganze Zeit lang. Und dann haben sie sich darauf festgesetzt.
Ich glaube, Schalke ist noch eine Nummer höher.
Irgendwie so ein bisschen zumindest.
Aber ist es nicht schwierig, wenn du einen Kader hast, der nicht zusammengestellt ist für einen Zweitegabstiegskampf und auf einmal sind nur noch Osnabrück und Braunschweig unter dir? Das ist keine gute Situation.
Ja, vor allem, du hast schon fünf Punkte Abstand zum rettenden Ufer. Das ist ja das Krasse, dass Platz 1 bis 15 innerhalb von acht Punkten sich tummelt. Das, was Tobi gesagt hat, du gewinnst zweimal, dann bist du schon irgendwie Aufsteiger quasi. Aber dann kommt ja der einzige Cut, den es in dieser Liga gibt. Der ist zu den letzten drei Teams und da ist Schalke auf der falschen Seite des Cuts, auf der Martin-Keimer-Seite des Cuts, würde man sagen. Ja, wir haben Schalke in der letzten Ligatur ja auch schon ein bisschen behandelt. Also alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die sich dafür interessieren, können da nochmal reinhören. Ein aktuelles Update ist immerhin, finanziell sieht es ganz gut aus. Man hat einen Gewinn gemacht und das trotz all der angespannten Situation. Gleichzeitig ist der ärme Sponsor aber kurz davor insolvent zu gehen oder zumindest abzuspringen. Also Schalke, ich sag's mal so, ich könnte hier in jeder Ligatur zur zweiten Liga über Schalke sprechen und das liegt an ganz, ganz vielen Dingen. Aber jetzt wollen wir uns ja auf eure drei Vereine konzentrieren und die Reihenfolge gibt dir hier auch die Tabelle vor und das ist diesmal ziemlich eindeutig. Tobi grinst schon über beide Ohren. Wir werden jetzt über Hannover 96 sprechen. Hannover, das mit 18 Punkten nach 10 Spielen, nur ein Punkt hinter Rang 3 liegt, zwei Punkte hinter Rang 1 und 2, also St. Pauli, Hannover und Heustern-Kiel sind die ersten drei. Dann kommt schon Hannover. Warum, Tobi? Was hat Hannover da oben verloren? Ich hab's nicht mehr für möglich gehalten.
Ja, da hättest du sicherlich in Hannover auch einige gefunden, die deine Meinung teilen. Ich könnte jetzt das ganz einfach machen und sagen, weil Martin Kidd nach dem ersten Spiel schon auf den Putz gehauen hat und gesagt hat, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Das ist natürlich völliger Quatsch.
Was ist nicht die Lösung all eurer Probleme in Hannover?
Ich glaub nicht. Ich lehne mich ganz weit aus dem Fenster. Ich glaube nicht. Also, es ist tatsächlich ja so, dass Hannover 96 jetzt in die Saison reingegangen ist mit einem Trainer, der schon etwas länger da ist, der also nicht irgendwie so kurz vor Ende der letzten Saison verpflichtet wurde. Wir haben einen Trainer, der schon mal gezeigt hat, dass er aufsteigen kann. Und wir haben einen Trainer, der man bis auf diesen kurzen Ausraster, den ich gerade nach dem ersten Spieltag, wo wir 2 zu 2 gegen Elbersberg gespielt haben. Jetzt nicht super geil, aber halt auch kein komplettes Desaster, insbesondere wenn man sich vielleicht heute die Tabelle nochmal anguckt. Man hat dem Trainer grundsätzlich schon Zeit gegeben und ein bisschen Ruhe, das Ganze vernünftig aufzubauen. Und der Trainer hat dann nach und nach vielleicht auch erkannt, mit welchen Spielern es besser funktioniert und mit welchen nicht ganz so gut. Und diese Ruhe, ich weiß nicht, ob sie nur in mir war oder ob sie vielleicht sogar im gesamten Umfeld von 96 war, diese Ruhe hat sich jetzt nach zehn Spieltagen definitiv bezahlt gemacht. Der Blick auf die Tabelle ist schön. Man hat Sachen, an denen man sich positiv orientieren kann. Also wir schießen zum Beispiel relativ viele Tore, was ungewöhnlich ist. Wir haben, obwohl es eine große Stürmer-Diskussion gab, wir brauchen unbedingt noch einen Stürmer und noch einen und noch einen, haben wir, finde ich, eine Mannschaft, die jetzt inzwischen sehr gefestigt ist. Wenn mal der eine oder andere ausfällt wegen einer roten Karte, dann lässt es sich trotzdem mit dem bestehenden Stamm sinnvoll ergänzen. Es ist so ungewöhnlich, du hast nicht ganz unrecht.
Man merkt richtig, dass du dich schwerer tust, als wenn du mir irgendeine Krise beschreiben musst bei Hannover 96.
Das geht ja auch locker von der Hand, das kann ich auch. Ich glaube, seitdem es den Rasenfunk gibt, geht es nur bergab mit 96.
Moment mal, der Rasenfunk hat damit nichts zu tun.
Nein, das ist nur der zeitliche Zusammenhang. Aber grundsätzlich ist es einfach im Moment relativ ruhig in Hannover. Es passiert nicht viel Schlechtes. Man hat ja so Saisons –da kommen wir sicherlich später auch noch zu –da verletzt sich einer der wichtigsten Spieler. Und du weißt genau, in der Hinrunde kannst du nicht mehr auf den Bauen. Kacke. So etwas passiert in Hannover im Moment auch selten. Wir waren schon eine Mannschaft, die jahrelang dafür gut war. Das waren immer ein oder zwei wichtige Leute. Irgendeine Verletzung hatten meistens ein Muskelding. Unterleitl –ich weiß nicht, was er macht, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist es auch viel Glück dabei. Aber unterleitl tritt das so gut wie nicht mehr auf. Also Trezoldi war jetzt mal länger krank, aber der hat sich halt mit irgendwas Infektionsmäßigen bei der U21-Nationalmannschaft angesteckt. Okay, kann passieren. Aber ansonsten, dass man so sagt, diese ganzen Verletzungen, die relativ oft auftreten, diese Saison nichts. Und deshalb kann der Trainer mit einem Stamm spielen, der immer wieder da ist und auf den er baut. Er hat am Anfang, wie gesagt, ein bisschen umbauen müssen. Aber jetzt hat er den definitiv gefunden. Und das gibt der Mannschaft Sicherheit und das siehst du.
Anna wollte schon vor fünf Minuten was sagen. Sie erträgt es, glaube ich nicht, Tobi.
Ich möchte gerne was sagen. Und zwar war es nicht so, Tobi, dass in Hannover ein bisschen Unruhe war, nachdem Eversberg das erste Tor der Saison geschossen hat. Sondern ihr seid einfach in St. Hausen aus dem Pokal ausgeschieden in der ersten Runde. Und bevor ihr auswärts in Rostock gewonnen habt, kann ich mich erinnern, also mindestens an zwei Personen im direkten Umfeld, die nervös waren und die gesagt haben, ja, ah Mensch, je nachdem, wie es jetzt in Rostock läuft, mal gucken, mal gucken. Und ich finde das schon erstaunlich. Und das betrachte ich als liebevolle Ergänzung, wie schnell sich sowas ändern kann, weil ich es total, als darüberstehende, vom Derby abgekoppelte Perspektive auf das Fußballgeschäft total wichtig und richtig fand, am Trainer festzuhalten, hatte aber den Eindruck, wenn das in Rostock nicht so gelaufen wäre, wäre das kompliziert geworden in Hannover, zumal die Rückrunde der letzten Saison nicht so gelaufen ist, wie ihr euch das vorgestellt habt.
Also ja, Rückrunde definitiv, umhörlich hinten raus. Wir erinnern uns an das 5 zu 1 zu Hause am letzten Spieltag gegen Kiel. Das war richtig, richtig böse. Deshalb, wie gesagt, es hat ja auch gescheppert schon quasi am ersten Spieltag, als Martin Kind sein großes Interview gegeben hat und gesagt hat, er sieht keine Weiterentwicklung und das ist alles Käse und so weiter und so fort. Ihr könnt es euch vorstellen, Martin Kind erzählt viel und dann auch relativ ungehemmt, die ganze Geschichte. Und ja, dieses Pokalspiel, ich will nicht sagen, dass ich das verdrängt habe, aber du verschaltest halt im Elfmeterschießen aus beim Drittligisten, bei einem damals sehr ambitionierten Drittligisten. Ich glaube, jetzt habe ich die Tabelle nicht vor Augen, aber inzwischen ist Sandhausen auch gar nicht mehr so weit oben. Das war natürlich hochgradig unangenehm und dieses Rostock-Spiel war wichtig. Ein Vorrang, weil danach der HSV kam, wo man ja auch nicht zwingend immer mit drei Punkten rechnen kann und in dem Fall auch überhaupt nicht konnte. Man darf aber auch nicht vergessen, Eversberg 2-0 zurückgelegen, 2-2 gemacht, in Nürnberg 2-0 geführt, in meinen Augen, ja, darf man das hier so deutlich sagen? Ich glaube, der Schiri hat da auf jeden Fall, schläft ja nicht in Hannover 96-Bettwäsche. Da gab es noch einen Elfmeter, der –egal. Also ein bisschen Glück, ein bisschen Pech will ich damit eigentlich nur sagen. Man hat sich einmal zurückgekämpft, einmal hat man eine Führung verspielt. Es war nicht alles so schlimm, wie es auf den ersten Blick aussah, im Pokal ausgeschieden. Ja, das war eher ein nicht so schöner Abend. Aber tatsächlich, seitdem läuft es. Und man kann es vielleicht auch tatsächlich dann an den Entscheidungen, die der Trainer nach diesem Spiel getroffen hat, vielleicht auch treffen musste, von was die Aufstellung angeht, betrachten. Und den Grund darin finden, dass man ein bisschen gezwungen wurde, neue Lösungen zu finden, insbesondere im Mittelfeld. Dass man Enzo Leopold wieder mehr Macht gegeben hat oder mehr Zeit gegeben hat. Dass man, ich weiß nicht was er genau mit solchen Leuten wie Louis Schaub gemacht hat, aber dass die sich auf einmal deutlich mehr reinhängen, dass die deutlich mehr Freude verbreiten. Und das war der Turning Point der Hinrunde, kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Das Spiel in Rostock, seitdem wird es besser. Wenn wir auf einzelne Spieler gucken, kann ich jetzt gerne weitermachen. Also Halstenberg ist jetzt ganz klar der Unterschied. Also Halstenberg und Ziele. Ziele hat der Weltmeister. Halstenberg der Champions League-Spieler. Du kannst in Hannover Ziele nicht sagen, ohne der Weltmeister. Das geht nicht, Max. Das hat man so drin. Es sagen halt wirklich immer noch Leute. Das ist kein Witz. Aber du merkst es. Das ist einer der besten Torwart der 2. Liga. Meinetwegen können wir uns auch auf die Top 3 runterreden. Ist mir egal. Am Ende Ziele und Halstenberg in Form. Und da sind sie halt jetzt erst geworden. Oder einfach an Halstenberg. Das macht einen riesengroßen Unterschied. Und ich habe gerade die ersten drei, vier Spiele viel auf Halstenberg geguckt. Der hat auch echt Mist gebaut. Also da waren viele Böcke drin. Da hast du gemerkt, der ist noch nicht so wirklich dabei. Wo ist jetzt keine Gründe von wegen nicht trainiert oder die Vorbereitung nicht mitgemacht. Ja, da mit Hannover nicht mitgemacht. Aber hat er in Leipzig mitgemacht. Also es gab durchaus keinen Grund, dass er irgendwie abfällt. Und seit Spieltag 4, Spieltag 5 gegen den HSV wurde es dann auf jeden Fall so langsam besser und geht in die richtige Richtung, ist er der Leader, den wir da haben wollten. Also der natürlich auch total überraschend zu uns gekommen ist. Das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen. Keine Sau hat damit gerechnet, dass wir einen Spieler von dem vorm Markt kriegen. Und wir sind doch alle einig, er ist nicht Hannover. Wir sind ja nur nach Hannover gekommen, weil Hannover die tolle sportliche Perspektive bietet, oder weil hier der Ball so schön fliegt. Nein, seine Heimat, er hat hier ganz, ganz früher mal ein bisschen gespielt, bevor er dann in die weite Welt ausgeflogen ist. Und er wollte halt aus familiären Gründen möglichst nah an zu Hause sein. Und das war unser Glück. Und deshalb haben wir den gekriegt. Und deshalb zahlen wir wahrscheinlich so wenig Geld, wie man für diesen Spieler eigentlich nur bezahlen kann. Also wenn man sehr, sehr viel Glück hat. Und der ist jetzt die Stärke. Ganz klarer Fall. Also ohne Marcel Halzenberg ist diese Abwehr ein deutliches Stückchen schlechter.
Und jetzt hast du ja aber gleichzeitig auch schon über den Sturm gesprochen. Und das ist ja wirklich interessant. Hannover 96, erfolgreichste Offensive, stand jetzt 10. Spieltag mit 22 Treffern. Aber sieben dieser Treffer kommen vom Spiel gegen den VfL Osnabrück. Susanne erinnerte sich sehr, sehr leidlich. Und wenn man böse sein...
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was da passiert ist.
Ehrlich gesagt weiß das wahrscheinlich Tobi auch nicht so genau, was da passiert ist. Oder? War das nicht so ein total verrücktes Spiel mit späten Toren und so?
Nee, so spät war es gar nicht. Aber ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht. Weil ich nämlich so wie Anna jetzt in Griechenland habe ich damals mich irgendwo zwischen Andorra und Südfrankreich rumgetrieben und habe das Spiel ganz klassisch im Radio nur gehört. Ich habe es mir natürlich hinterher noch mal ein bisschen der Zusammenfassung angeguckt und auch reichlich erzählen lassen. Wir gehen 1-0 in Führung, haben durchaus die Chance zurückzuliegen oder zumindest, dass es unentschieden in die Halbzeit geht, machen das 2-0 zur Halbzeit und dann machen wir fünf Tore in der zweiten Hälfte. Da lief es einfach, ich glaube, gegen einen Gegner, wir wissen doch alle, wie Fußball so funktioniert. Wenn du dann weiter versuchst, noch ein Tor zu machen, anstelle von Osnabrück, dann ist das eine ganz dumme Idee. Das war wirklich eine ganz dumme Idee an dem Tag. Und 96 hatte Bock und die haben die auseinandergefiedelt und dann geht das halt 7-0 aus. Geschenkt. Deshalb finde ich auch diesen Blick auf diese Torstatistik ein bisschen sehr verfälscht.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass trotzdem bei dem Spiel Lennart Grill, also der Torwart, der das VfL immer noch der beste Mann auf dem Platz war, also dann kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen, was da noch hätte passieren können.
Das war wirklich wild. Also das passiert uns auch nicht nochmal und euch wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Hoffen wir es.
Das war ein einmaliges Freak-Ergebnis. Deshalb auch die Anzahl der geschossenen Tore so ein bisschen verzerrt. Aber ist egal, es gibt ein gutes Gefühl und du hast was, wo man sich dran festhalten kann in Hannover.
Ja, und gleichzeitig war das ja schon so ein… Also ich hatte das Gefühl, das hat so ein Signal ausgesendet. Also jetzt ist Hannover da, jetzt läuft alles. Wenn ich jetzt aber ganz ketzerisch sein wollen würde, Tobi, dann würde ich schon darauf hinweisen, naja, also gegen die richtig guten Teams, gegen den HSV, gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf, Kaiserslautern kann man vielleicht noch dazuzellen. Und die einzige Ausnahme ist jetzt am Spieltag, am letzten Spieltag Magdeburg gewesen tatsächlich. Das sind jetzt Teams der oberen Tabellenregion. Die hat man mit Ausnahme von Magdeburg gegen keinen von denen gewonnen und die Siege dann eben geholt gegen Wien-Wiesbaden, gegen Osnabrück. Bei Hansa Rostek, gut, die waren damals auch Tabellenführer, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber bei Elvesberg dann das 2-2 und so weiter. Also müssen wir da jetzt auch ein bisschen über Spielplan reden? Bin ich da zu gemein nach zehn Spieltagen?
Die Antwort ist ja ein. Also du hast auf der einen Seite Recht, auf der anderen Seite passt es nicht so ganz. Wo du Recht hast, ist, dass wenn ich jetzt den Blick nach vorne werfe, sehe, dass da eher noch die Mannschaften von oben kommen, die sich jetzt dann nach und nach da oben auch festspielen. Das ist etwas, was mir eher Sorgen macht. Was mir aber Hoffnung wiederum gibt, ist, dass wir zwar gegen den HSV 1 zu 0 verloren haben, dass wir in Düsseldorf nur 1-1 gespielt haben und in Körderslautern 3 zu 1 verloren haben, dass das aber jetzt nicht so sagt über das Spiel, wie sie eigentlich waren. Also gegen den HSV, das war ein Top-Spiel, haben beide richtig guten Fußball gespielt, verlierst du 1 zu 0, kann passieren. Also wir haben vielleicht ein bisschen viel angeboten, haben deshalb das Tor gekriegt, okay, das hätte besser laufen können. In Düsseldorf, glaube ich, haben wir 1-0 geführt, dann das 1 zu 1 gekriegt und da sehe ich dann tatsächlich den positiven Schritt, dass wir es dann nicht mehr verloren haben, sondern gegen eine wirklich gute Düsseldorfer Mannschaft zu Ende gespielt haben. Und das Ding 3 zu 1 in Körderslautern, ich weiß, jetzt sage ich zum zweiten Mal, dass ich mit dem Schiri nicht sonderlich zufrieden war. Ich will auch wirklich als Mannschaft, die relativ viele Elfmeter zugesprochen kriegt, jetzt hier nicht auf die Tränendrüse drücken. Aber das war eine Verkettung sehr ungünstiger Umstände. Wir machen eigentlich das 2 zu 0. Ich habe bis heute keinen Videobeweis gesehen, dass das tatsächlich abseits war. Aber es wird schon abseits gewesen sein, 100%. Der VHR hat, glaube ich, noch nie was falsch gemacht. Und auf der Gegenseite gibt es einen Elfmeter für Körderslautern 1-1. Und der Rest ist dann wie immer auf dem Betze unangenehm. Weil einfach die Stimmung, das können wir nicht so gut, habe ich das Gefühl. Deshalb habe ich auch Angst vor Schalke. Aber egal, was ich damit sagen will. Wir haben zwar gegen die da oben bisher nur einen Punkt geholt. Aber es waren immer Spiele, wo wir mit dabei waren, wo wir unsere Chancen hatten, wo wir zumindest zweimal geführt haben gegen Düsseldorf und gegen Kaiserslautern. Und deshalb ist mir gar nicht so Angst und Bange, was die Spiele jetzt in der kommenden, oder in der zweiten Hälfte der Hinrunde betrifft.
Und das wird ja sehr wahrscheinlich auch mit der Spielweise zu tun haben. Über die würde ich gerne noch kurz sprechen. Weil du hast jetzt schon so ein paar Namen genannt. Du hast Enzo Leopold in neuer Rolle oder mit ein bisschen mehr Freiheiten im Spiel genannt. Du hast Marcel Hasenberg genannt. Du hast Ron Robert Zieler, Weltmeister genannt. Siehst du, ich kann es auch schon nicht mal anders machen. Aber wer ist denn sonst noch wichtig gerade bei Hannover 96?
Wer ist noch wichtig bei Hannover 96? Es ist ein kleiner Kreis, finde ich. Also es sind jetzt nicht so, dass wir, wie die letzten Jahre, immer sagen können, ja, wir haben 14, 15, 16 Spieler und ich weiß gar nicht, wer spielen soll. Ich finde, wir haben einen relativ kleinen, wichtigen Kreis. Zieler hatten wir gesagt, Halstenberg, gar keine Frage. Philipp Neumann in der Innenverteidigung und davor Herr Leopold, der in meinen Augen im Moment der beste oder zumindest der aufstrebendste Spieler in der Mannschaft ist und mir am meisten Freude bereitet. Und dann hängt ganz viel davon ab, wie viele Freiheiten Derek Köhn hat. Ich weiß nicht, vor der Saison gab es ja die eine oder andere Diskussion, ob er vielleicht in die Bundesliga wechselt. Und ich habe relativ großzügig gesagt, bitte, wenn einer kommt und zwei, drei Millionen für den bezahlt, bitte verkaufen, der macht uns keine größere Freude. Außer, dass er einen richtig guten Schuss hat. Aber im Spiel ist er mir nicht angenehm genug. Der gibt mir keine Sicherheit. Der spielt linken Verteidiger in der Fünferkette und turnt da eigentlich nie rum. Und das war letztes Jahr oft das Problem, dass der irgendwo da vorne war und für Offensivfußball gesorgt hat, aber hinten zu wenig Absicherung. Und das ist der große Change gewesen in dieser Saison, was Leitel bei uns auf die Reihe gekriegt hat. Er hat nämlich, auch wenn es immer so aussieht, dass wir mit einer Fünferkette spielen in der Verteidigung, eigentlich spielen wir nur mit einer Viererkette. Weil Derek Köhne alle Freiheiten der Welt hat. Der darf quasi, wenn der vorne rumläuft, ist völlig egal. Dann rückt alles so ein Stückchen nach links. R&B spielt den linken Verteidiger, dann wir spielen Viererkette mit zwei Innenverteidigern. Manchmal lässt sich Herr Kunze noch zurückfallen. Das funktioniert meistens sehr, sehr gut. Wo es übrigens nicht funktioniert hat, war im Spiel gegen Magdeburg. Magdeburg, ich weiß nicht, Christian Titz hat irgendwie aufgepasst. Er hat gesagt, wenn wir heute einen richtig beschäftigen, dann ist es den Köhn. Der hatte gar keine Chance, der ist überhaupt nicht nach vorne gekommen. Der musste immer hinten arbeiten. Aber wenn das nicht passiert, ist das etwas, was sehr, sehr schön anzusehen ist, dass wir so eine Dreier-, Fünferkette vortäuschen, aber tatsächlich Viererkette spielen, weil Herr Köhn ist überhaupt nicht mit eingeplant in der Geschichte und dann über die linke Seite Attacke macht. Also, um noch zum Abschluss zu kommen, was die Leute angeht, die wirklich, wirklich wichtig sind, torchert am Elfmeterpunkt, die ersten 60 Minuten danach darf er immer duschen gehen. Ich weiß nicht, warum, das ist wirklich faszinierend. Trotzdem schon acht Tore gemacht, oder? Ja, er macht da seine Tore und dann darf er… Ich glaube, wenn man das auswertet, wahrscheinlich geht er zwei von drei Spiele, ist er in der 65. schon auf der Bank. Ganz komisch, aber er gibt natürlich bis dahin alles und hat dann vielleicht auch nicht mehr die Puste. Und ansonsten ist es ein bisschen beliebig, also ob Nielsen spielt oder Schaub spielt auch schon meistens. Oder Vogelsammer, der jetzt reingekommen ist, den wir frisch verpflichtet haben, der gefällt mir auch. Der hängt sich ordentlich rein. Das hat mich positiv überrascht. Ich dachte, das war so eine Last-Minute-Versweiflungsverpflichtung. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein guter. Der passt da ganz gut rein. Oder Trezoy, die dann auch vorne im Sturm. Das ist alles nicht so wichtig. Ich glaube, die wirklich wichtige Party geht dahinter ab und allen voran auch, wie der Gegner Derek Köhne beschäftigt und wie er sich dann mit Dies und Das auf dem Platz beschäftigen kann.
Hat sich denn da was in der Transferstrategie verändert? Wir haben jetzt relativ viele Spieler genannt. Einige Spieler mit Vergangenheit bei der Zweiten von Bayern, Köhne und RMB. Enzo Leopold kommt ja von Freiburg 2. Phil Neumann hat dann auf Schalke gespielt, dann bei Kiel und jetzt. Aber kam letztlich auch aus der U19 von Schalke. Der wurde noch damals von Pepo im Blauen Salon interviewt. Die Altvorderen unter dem Podcast-Hörenden, die erinnern sich noch, was das für ein Format damals war. Also hat sich da was verändert? Die großen Investitionen sehe ich jetzt hier in den letzten Jahren bei Hannover 96 nicht mehr.
Ja, in den letzten Jahren, genau. Wenn du noch Veränderungen fragst, dann würde ich sagen, spätestens seit dem zweiten Abstieg haben wir keine Spieler mehr gekauft, die signifikant Geld gekostet haben. Auch in der 2. Liga kann man ja ein bisschen Geld ausgeben für Spieler, aber ich glaube, wahrscheinlich unterschlage ich jetzt irgendeinen, aber so einen siebenstelligen Betrag, also irgendwas mit einer Million, das funktioniert nicht mehr in Hannover. Wir haben verkauft wie die Großen, also alles, was irgendwie Geld bringt. Deshalb dachte ich, dass der Köln auch geht, weil drei, vier Millionen vielleicht im Raum standen. Aber alles, was irgendwie Geld gebracht hat, haben wir natürlich verkauft. Da gibt es Gründe, da könnten wir wahrscheinlich zwei Tribütengespräche drüber führen. Deshalb war es schon immer das Credo in Hannover, nicht so viel Geld auszugeben, lieber Herr Sportdirektor, wir müssen sparen. Vielleicht haben wir jetzt gerade eine Phase, wo wir vielleicht ein bisschen besser picken in dem, was wir tun. Es gab so viele böse Worte über das Scouting in Hannover, dass das von einem einzelnen älteren Herrn durchgeführt wird. Es ist inzwischen definitiv nicht mehr so. Es gucken vielleicht auch andere Leute mal nach Spielern, als dieser hier nicht weiter erwähnte Herr.
Jetzt ist es ein gar nicht so alter Mann, Markus.
Ja, der macht das nicht alleine, aber die Leute drumherum. Nicht, dass wir aneinander vorbeirehen. Also, Schatzschneider war ja lange Zeit der große Scouting-Man in Hannover und hat dies und das gescoutet, keine Ahnung. Inzwischen ist das alles sicherlich ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt und ein bisschen besser aufgestellt. Ich finde, Herr Mann macht sehr gute Arbeit. Da sind viele Verpflichtungen dabei, die gut sind. Das kann nicht jeder treffen, gar keine Frage. Er hat sich auch von dem einen oder anderen getrennt. Den hat er losgewonnen, der vielleicht dann doch zu viel gewesen wäre im Kader. Und deshalb, ich finde, das klappt ganz gut und hat sich in den letzten anderthalb, zwei Jahren verbessert. Aber das wir kein Geld haben, hat sich nicht geändert.
Tobi, ich habe dich noch nie so euphorisch zu Hannover 96 erlebt im Rasenburg. Ich habe auch ein bisschen Angst, jetzt damit was kaputt zu machen, das jetzt hier quasi gebannt zu haben auf Podcast-Celefano oder wie man das ausdrücken möchte. Aber das klingt ja ganz fantastisch. Das könnte dieses Jahr wirklich klappen, oder darfst du es nicht aussprechen?
Du meinst jetzt wieder Aufstieg, dies das. Aber es kann natürlich klappen, es kann jede Saison klappen, gar keine Frage. Der Start war auch ganz okay. Aber ich würde uns weiterhin nicht zu den drei Aufstiegsfavoriten zählen. Und jetzt mal ganz unter uns. Wir haben vorhin gesagt, wie schön die 2. Liga ist. Hast du dir mal die erste angeguckt, Max? Ich möchte da nicht.
Hast du dir mal die erste angeguckt? Weißt du, wie du hier sprichst? Ich bin der Einzige, der da auch hinguckt.
Das ist tatsächlich ein privater Hintergrund, der uns verbindet, Tobi und mich, dass wir uns kennengelernt haben, in dem kurz nach dem ersten Abstieg von Hannover 96 und ich ihn in Hamburg fand, am Boden zerstört und ihm ein Wochenende davon erzählt habe, wie schön die zweite Liga eigentlich ist. Tobi, und das ist aus dir geworden.
Ich dachte, was will diese verrückte Frau von mir? Was erzählt die denn da? Es hat nur 7, 8 Jahre gedauert und schon hat es gewirkt. Also um das nochmal ganz ernsthaft abzuschließen vielleicht. Klar, Ausstieg muss allein aus finanziellen Gründen immer das Ziel sein. Das Geld, was da oben verdient wird, ist einfach so unfassbar viel, dass es Hannover 96 nur gut tun kann. Ich ganz persönlich fühle mich hochgradig wohl in der 2. Liga. Es wird immer gut durchgetauscht. Es steigen mindestens zwei ab, mindestens zwei steigen auf. Diese Saison finde ich wirklich so viele Premium-Vereine dabei, wie seit langer, langer Zeit nicht mehr. Und ja, ich würde vielleicht wirklich gerne mal wieder nach München fahren, Max, und dann können wir vielleicht auch ein Getränk zusammen trinken. Aber vielleicht kriegt es 1860 ja irgendwie hin, dass sie irgendwann mal nach oben kommen oder so. Ich muss dafür nicht in die Bundesliga.
Dann kriegst du eher nochmal NFL-Karten in München, ehrlich gesagt.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Nein, aber ganz ehrlich, was würde es Hannover 96 für einen Spaß bringen oder was würde es mir als Fan, als 96 Fan für einen Spaß bringen, nach Dortmund, nach Leipzig, nach München zu fahren? Ja, 4-0, 4-1 und 3-0 verloren. Juhu, da freuen wir uns aber. Nee, zweite Liga, das ist das Geschäft. Das macht richtig Bock.
Okay, wir merken uns das, aber ich freue mich, diesen Zwischenstand zu hören und dass du quasi angekommen bist, dass du die Liga gefunden hast, die du offenbar die ganze Zeit gebraucht hast. Tobi, das ist schön zu wissen. Es stellt sich die Frage, wie sich das für den VfL Osnabrück so darstellt, Susanne. Da ist ja die Situation logischerweise eine andere. Wir alle haben den Aufstieg mitbekommen. Wir wissen, Tobi Schweinsteiger hat sich da in einige Herzen gebracht mit seinen Spielern natürlich.
Und auf die eine oder andere Hauswand.
Auf die eine oder andere Hauswand, ja.
Gibt jetzt einen Graffiti in Osnabrück. Ähnlich jetzt schon an Tobi Schweinsteiger. Auf eine Pizzeria, wo er regelmäßig hingeht. Riesengroß. Wenn man nach Osnabrück reinfährt, also von einer anderen Richtung, dann sieht man das ja.
Aber er hat da nicht auch so eine Kochmütze auf und einen Pizzakarton in der Hand. Ach, schade. Schade. Das hätte ich sehr gerne gesehen. Aber wie ist denn die Lage beim VfL? Also 6 Punkte nach 10 Spielen, 1 Sieg, 3 Unentschieden, 11 zu 23 Tore. Wobei wir ja schon wissen, 7 davon kamen bei Hannover zustande. Und da werden sich noch so manche in eine Packung holen, wenn ich das Segment jetzt richtig verstanden habe. Also wie ist die Lage beim VfL?
Ja, nicht so dolle, wenn man es mal so umschreiben will. Also vor allem nach dem 0-2 jetzt gegen Wiesbaden am Wochenende, muss man halt sagen, das war schon nochmal so ein... Ja, also dieses 0-7 Hannover, ja, das war schlimm. Für mich persönlich war das auch schlimm, weil ich es vom Fernseher gesehen habe mit einem alten Bekannten, den ich endlich mal eingeladen habe, dass wir mal zusammen Fußball schauen. Und dann hat er gesagt, guck nie wieder mit dir. Aber das war wirklich kein schon am Nachmittag. Nur dieses 0-7 hat eben was ausgelöst beim VfL. Und zwar, dass man sich nochmal neu sortiert hat. Die Mannschaft hat sich dann zusammengesetzt. Man hat nochmal Ziele formuliert, hat nochmal geguckt, woran hat es denn gelegen, was will man denn verändern. So ein Prozess, der angeschoben worden ist, aber der sich auch aus dem Team herausgestaltet hat. Und dann kam der HSV und 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Und auf einmal war natürlich eine gewisse Euphorie da. Jetzt kann man sagen, HSV in Osnabrück, das sind immer drei sichere Punkte. Also die haben da schon Ewigkeiten. Kein Pflichtspiel mehr gewonnen und viele hintereinander verloren. Dann kamen Kaiserslautern und Düsseldorf. Die behälten 2-2 an der Bremer Brücke und in Düsseldorf dann das 1-1. Das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen der Gegenentwurf zu dem, was Tobi gerade gesagt hat, zu Hannover 96. Nämlich, der VfL kann es ganz gut gegen die großen Mannschaften. Und dann kommen wir in Wiesbaden und die Erwartungshaltung ist natürlich enorm. Und plötzlich kriegst du 0-2 und hast gefühlt auch irgendwie bis auf 15 Minuten oder 20 Minuten in der zweiten Halbzeit bist du eigentlich auch überhaupt nicht drin im Spiel. Und ja, kannst du überhaupt nicht dagegenhalten gefühlt. Und das ist halt etwas gewesen, was hier schon zu einem gewissen Frust und zu einer Enttäuschung und auch einem Ärger geführt hat. Und zwar so bei allen, also beim Trainer, bei den Spielern, auch so im Umfeld und bei den Fans so ein bisschen.
Aber kann man sagen, weil du gesagt hast, das 7 zu 0 oder das 0 zu 7, besser gesagt, das hätte eben so einen Prozess angestoßen und dass man sich da eben zusammengesetzt hätte. Was hat man denn da dann festgestellt, was sich quasi ändern muss? Und könnte das jetzt auch dann eine Erklärung sein für so eine Wien-Wiesbaden-Niederlage?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also nach dem 0 zu 7, das muss man halt auch sagen, also erstmal ist da ziemlich viel intern geblieben, was sie da besprochen haben, aber die Umstellung war danach, dass man halt auf einmal in beim 2 zu 1 auf einmal bestimmte Faktoren hatte, die vorher nicht da waren. Also z. Cuisens, der ja kam kurz vor dem Hannover-Spiel, der in Hannover ja auch ein bisschen gespielt hat, war dann auf einmal fester integriert in dieser Mannschaft und hat gefühlt jeden um sich herum besser gemacht. Also das war so ein wichtiger Faktor nochmal als Schlüsseltransfer, auch als überraschender Transfer. Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich war eigentlich als er verpflichtet worden ist bzw. ausgeliehen worden ist, war ich quasi schon auf dem Nachhauseweg. Letzter Transfertag, war klar, es kommt nichts mehr. Und auf einmal kriege ich einen Anruf vom VfL, du gehst gleich eine Pressemitteilung raus, wir haben noch jemanden verpflichtet. Da habe ich gesagt, damit ich jetzt umdrehe, muss aber ein Knaller kommen. Ja, war dann auch. Naja, auf jeden Fall, der war so ein entscheidender Faktor. Dann hat man mit Jannis Wulf jemanden reingebracht. Du hast es gerade gesagt, jeder erinnert sich noch an den Aufstieg, 90. plus 6, der dann das Tor gemacht hat und bis heute, glaube ich, noch gar nicht so richtig realisiert hat, was eben da passiert ist. Und der ist so jemand, so Straßenfußballer. Das ist dem scheißegal, ob der Bundesliga, dritte Liga, vierte Liga, fünfte spielt, egal. Der spielt halt seinen Stiefel da runter quasi. Und das ist manchmal ganz gut. Also der hat auf einmal so eine gewisse Leichtigkeit und Frische reingebracht auch. Conté konnte plötzlich seine Schnelligkeit ausspielen. Ja, und wie gesagt, mit Cuisance halt eben derjenige, der dann halt auch nochmal das Ganze, ja, um sich herum einfach jeden so ein bisschen auf ein anderes Niveau gehoben hat. Und dann kam natürlich noch hinzu, gefühlt immer HSV, Kaiserslautern, Düsseldorf. Das sind so für einen VfL immer wie so Pokalspiele. Also so, ich weiß nicht, ob man das kennt, ne, von Mannschaften, die dann halt eben auf einmal gegen einen Bundesligisten spielen und sich richtig zusammenreisen und nochmal ein Stück draufwerfen und so. Und dann war auch HSV dann Freitagabend, Bremer Brücke, Flutlicht, ist natürlich auch immer cool. Ja, und das waren halt so viele verschiedene Faktoren. Ob man die jetzt nach dem 0-2 gegen Wiesbaden auch wieder herzaubern kann, weiß ich nicht. Aber was, glaube ich, ganz entscheidend jetzt sein wird und auch wichtig ist, ist, dass eben beim 0-2 schon dabei war Timo Behrmann, der Kapitän, der hat sich in der Vorbereitung verletzt. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Spieler hier beim VfL. Schon ewig, also was heißt ewig, aber lange für den VfL gespielt, lange für Heidenheim und jetzt ist er schon wieder hier beim VfL in der 3. Liga, seit zwei Jahren da und in der 2. Liga halt eben als wichtige Stütze eingebaut und eingeplant. Und dass der wieder zurück ist, das ist, glaube ich, ganz entscheidend. Also, dass man halt jemand auf dem Feld hat, einen Leader, der jetzt auch da vorangeht, der eben halt auch mit Kampf und Einsatz noch mal bestimmte Tugende mit reinbringt. Das ist, glaube ich, ein entscheidender Faktor, könnte das sein.
Ja, so ein weiterer guter Innenverteidiger kann definitiv nicht Schaden bei 23 Gegend treffen.
Ja, wobei man auch sagen muss, es hat nicht immer nur daran gelegen.
Jaja, genau. Also das wollte ich damit auch nicht angedeutet haben. Aber ich höre da jetzt schon erstaunlich viel Ratlosigkeit raus. Was heißt Ratlosigkeit? Aber es ist fast schon Ernüchterung. Gerade weil der Aufstieg so emotional war, dachte ich eigentlich, das würde noch länger in die Saison reintragen. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch kein Muss für Osnabrück, 2. Liga zu spielen. Das ist natürlich toll und das sieht man wahrscheinlich auch als Chance. Der große Wunsch ist, irgendwie möglichst so lange da drin zu bleiben, wie es geht. Wir haben ja gerade gelernt, es ist die beste Liga, es ist der schönste Ort, an dem man sein möchte. Als Verein. Aber davon spüre ich jetzt bei dem, was du sagst, nicht mehr so viel.
Na, nicht unbedingt. Also die Euphorie ist schon –was heißt die Euphorie? Aber es ist, das kann hier auch ganz schnell gehen. Also lass den VfL mal, wie gesagt, Freitagabend Bremer Brücke Flutlicht an und zack, sie ist auf einmal wieder alles angezündet. Ich glaube, das wird auch entscheidend sein, dass du jetzt eben diese Bremer Brücke dann auch nutzt. Wir haben jetzt einen Podcast, wir haben es ja vorhin angesprochen, wir haben den Brücken geflüstert. Podcast haben wir gestern auch hier in dem Studio aufgezeichnet, wo ich gerade sitze. Da war Lothar Gans dabei, der ehemalige –ja, Mr. VfL kann man ihn eigentlich schon nennen –hier als Spieler, als Trainer, als Manager lange Zeit aktiv. Der kennt die Brücke in und auswendig. Und der hat ganz klar auch gesagt, wir müssen jetzt gucken, dass wir hier zu Hause wieder es schaffen, dass es vom Spielfeld zu dieser Funke auch überspringt, auf die Fans, weil die sind da. Das Stadion ist regelmäßig ausverkauft, die Zuschauer kommen. Die waren auch letztes Jahr in der dritten Liga schon da. Übrigens nicht erst seitdem es gut lief, sondern auch schon am Anfang, als man ja kurz vor der Winterpause noch quasi gegen den Abstieg gespielt hat. Das wissen vielleicht gar nicht so viele, aber da hat Tobias Schweinsteiger hier in einem Interview bei uns quasi den Abstiegskampf ausgerufen. Das war kurz vor dem Wäppenspiel. Und danach ging es dann auf einmal aufwärts. Da waren aber auch schon die Zuschauer hier an der Bremer Brücke. Und es war eine hohe Auslastung. Also, was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass man dieses Pfund jetzt einfach auch nutzen muss. Man muss gucken, dass man da wieder eine Stimmung reinbringt und dass man eben zu Hause diese Bremer Brücke wieder als eine Ortschaft, wo Mannschaften ungern hinfahren und wo man selbst wieder begeisterte Spiele bekommt und sich da auch Selbstvertrauen holt.
Jetzt wollte ich gerade nachgucken, wo der VfL in der Heimtabelle liegt. Das ist leider auch der letzte Platz, aber immerhin 4 der 6 Punkte hat man da geholt.
Ja, trotzdem, es ist halt schwierig. Du musst halt zu Hause eigentlich, ja, das wie gesagt schaffen, so diesen Spirit, den du von diesem HSV-Spiel zum Beispiel hattest oder gegen Kaiserslautern. Ich meine, es war dann zwar auch unglücklich mit Lautern. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Spiel auch in Erinnerung habt. 2 zu 0 geführt, dann hält Grill 2, 11 Meter ganz stark und dann kriegst du in der siebten Minute der Nachspielzeit kriegt Diakite, der Innenverteidiger, der Timo Behrmann und Niklas Wiemann, den gesperrtenen, vertreten hat. Der hat sich an der Schulter verletzt und er hat die Schulter quasi den Arm angebunden und genau dahin kriegt er dann den Ball. Und von dort aus geht er ins Tor 2-2 und das war natürlich schon auch fies. Aber trotzdem, bis dahin war die Stimmung halt eben auch gut. Und das muss man einfach nutzen. Und vor allem dann auch gegen die kleineren Mannschaften. Du hast es wie gesagt vorhin angesprochen, Tobi, da tut sich Hannover immer leichter. Und gegen die Großen schwer. Beim VfL ist es wie gesagt eher ein bisschen umgekehrt. Dann gegen die Kleineren zu Hause, wenn man schon nicht vielleicht gewinnt, dann wenigstens nicht verlieren. Weil dann hast du gleich eben den Abstand auch noch mal viel, viel größer.
Ja, also gegen wen? Wiesbaden und gegen Elvesberg jeweils 0 zu 2 und 0 zu 1 verloren. Das tut dann schon weh, wenn man sich anguckt, wie ja auch die Tabellenkonstellation so ist. Also Elvesberg ist ja so ein bisschen der Gegenentwurf gerade zum VfL. Auch mit aufgestiegen, aber halt deutlich mehr Punkte. Und zwar mehr als doppelt so viele Punkte. Jetzt kennt man glaube ich Tobias Schweinsteiger als Typ schon so ein bisschen, weil er ist ja auch relativ bekannt und gerade durch den Aufstieg auch hatte ich das Gefühl, dass er mehr Medienpräsenz hatte. Aber was ist denn das eigentlich für ein Fußball, den der VfL spielt? Und warum ist man dann so abhängig von Heimspielen? Weil ich verstehe alles, was du sagst mit dem Einfluss des Stadions und so weiter, aber in der perfekten Welt schafft man es natürlich auswärts schon auch hin und wieder mal was mitzunehmen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das wollte ich auch damit nicht sagen. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass man sich da das Selbstvertrauen holen kann. Und das ist halt eben recht –was heißt einfach –aber das geht halt gut, wenn du dann diesen Spirit sozusagen von dieser Brücke mitnimmst, auch in die Auswärtsspiele. Was Schweinsteiger für einen Fußball spielen lässt? Ja, eigentlich lässt er gar nicht so einen anderen Fußball spielen wie in der dritten Liga. Also sie haben ihr 4-3-3, was sich etabliert hat als System. Und das ist ein Fußball, der Spaß macht zuzuschauen, wenn es gut läuft. Und das vielleicht auch ein Mittengrund ist, warum sie gegen Mannschaften, wie zum Beispiel vielleicht den HSV oder Lautern oder Düsseldorf, auch mal ein bisschen besser ausschauen, weil sie eben versuchen mitzuspielen. Und weil sie dann gegen so Mannschaften wie Wien, Wiesbaden, die dann mit einer Viererkette vor der Fünferkette stehen und einfach alles dicht machen und dann noch mit so Riesenprügeltypen da hinten drin stehen, sich dann halt manchmal ein bisschen schwieriger tun. Andererseits, ja, Tobi grinst jetzt schon. Manchmal geht es eben halt auch in die Hecke, dann dieses Mitspielen, wie gegen Hannover 96. Aber gut, das passiert dann halt auch mal.
Es geht in die Hecke ist aber eine ganz wunderbare Formulierung. Die habe ich gerade zum ersten Mal gehört, glaube ich. Die werde ich mir merken. Jetzt hast du schon Croissants genannt. Endlich hat er anscheinend den Verein gefunden, bei dem er glänzen kann. Das ist ja auch eine Odyssee, die er dadurch gemacht hat. Du hast vorhin auch schon Lennart Grill genannt, der ja offenbar mindestens schon zwei gute Spieler hatte. Ich habe gelernt, Man of the Match eigentlich beim 0 zu 7 und zwei Elfmeter gehalten gegen Kaiserslautern. Aber wer sind denn sonst noch so wichtige Figuren?
Wie gesagt, Timo Behrmann. Jetzt als der Kapitän, der wieder zurück ist, der wird einfach ganz wichtig sein, weil er viele dieser jungen Spieler, die noch ganz wenig Zweitliga-Erfahrung haben, also wenn du dir das anguckst, die Viererkette, die da in Hannover gespielt hat, da waren teilweise Leute drin wie Niklas Wibmann, der hat letztes Jahr noch im Winter in der Vierten Liga agiert. Das ist natürlich wichtig, dass du da jemanden hast, der diese Mannschaft dann führt. Und dann auf jeden Fall natürlich noch Robert Tesche zu nennen, der auch mit seiner ganzen Erfahrung –das ist jetzt nicht der Lautsprecher auf dem Platz und der dirigiert nicht unbedingt seine Leute, aber das ist so ein Spieler, der halt unglaublich viel Sicherheit gibt, allein dadurch, dass er da steht und dass er da spielt und seine Erfahrung irgendwie einbringt. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Faktor. Und im Sturm würde ich gerade im Moment Erik Engelhardt nennen. Der ist auch Topscorer im Moment mit vier Toren. Und das ist ein Kämpfertyp. Ist auch ein Franke, wie ich. Und freut sich schon auf das Spiel in Fürth. Hat da irgendwie schon zehn Tickets geordert für die ganze Familie. Ich hoffe, dass er da auch ganz gut performt, wie man so schön sagt. Ja, das ist ein Kämpfertyp. Das ist so ein richtiger Wühler, der arbeitet unendlich auch. Manchmal denkt man sich, was ist denn jetzt dahin gerade los, weil der am eigenen 16er da irgendwie rumrennt, weil er da noch den Ball mit verteidigt. Das ist jemand, der auch seinem Gegenspieler unglaublich auf die Nerven fällt dadurch. Der kann ein wichtiger Faktor sein, weil wenn er das jetzt schafft, dass er vorne regelmäßig trifft, das könnte dem Ganzen guttun. Vielleicht als Letztes noch Florian Kleinhansel zu nennen, der sich auch ganz gut entwickelt hat. Er ist ein Linksverteidiger und spielt eine starke erste Zweitligasaison für sich. Auch in den letzten Jahren beim VfL hat er sich sukzessive weiterentwickelt. Das sind vielleicht die wichtigsten.
Florian Kleinhansel, wo man sich nicht sicher ist, linksverteidiger beim VfL Osnabrück oder dann doch irgendwie Nebenrolle beim Bergdoktor.
Aber ein unglaublich netter Typ wirklich.
Bei dem Namen muss er das ja sein. Klingt schon sehr sympathisch. Ich kenne ihn natürlich überhaupt nicht. Aber sag mir doch mal, wo will denn der VfL Osnabrück hin? Also jetzt gar nicht gemessen an Erfolg, weil alle sagen natürlich immer, ja, wir wollen irgendwie die 2. Liga und wollen uns da etablieren. Aber wie ist denn der VfL aufgestellt? Was ist quasi das, mit dem man versucht, sowohl Spieler davon zu überzeugen, zum VfL zu kommen und eben auch sich dann eben seinen Platz ja irgendwo ja wahrscheinlich zwischen 2. und 3. Liga zu sichern?
Ja, also vor einigen Jahren hat der VfL schon mal recht deutlich dieses Ziel, wir wollen etablierter Zweitligist werden, ausgerufen. Das schwirrt schon noch in den Köpfen immer mit, aber gerade wenn man sich diese 2. Liga jetzt anguckt, wir haben ja vorhin schon darüber gesprochen, es heißt ja immer die beste 2. Liga aller Zeit, die wird ja schon seit 10 Jahren ausgerufen vor jeder Saison, aber ich glaube, diesmal kann man es wirklich mal so sagen. Und ja, womit kann der VfL überzeugen? Der VfL versucht natürlich alles, gerade wenn es zum Beispiel darum geht, auch neue Spieler oder auch die Fans zu überzeugen, deshalb mit seiner Tradition punkten, mit diesem Stadion. Und steigt da jetzt auch sehr viel ein in gewisse Werte, die er vertritt, also sprich Enkeltagiligkeit, Nachhaltigkeit und dergleichen und versucht sich da ein bisschen unabhängig auch vom sportlichen Erfolg, wobei es immer klar ist, dass es nicht ganz geht, aber auch etwas unabhängiger vom sportlichen Erfolg zu machen in seiner Attraktivität und diese Marke sozusagen VfL zu stärken. Also ich sag mal jetzt St. Pauli als ein Beispiel, die das ja geschafft haben, sich als Marke wirklich komplett unabhängig eigentlich von ihrem sportlichen Erfolg zu machen. Schön, dass jetzt beides wieder zusammenkommt, aber der VfL versucht halt auch so ein bisschen in so eine Richtung zu gehen, sich zu positionieren. Ja und ob es dann eben sportlich reicht, das müssen wir mal gucken. Also vielleicht können wir uns ja in dieser Runde, in der Rückrunde nochmal sehen, denn das muss man auch sagen, der VfL hat es wirklich in den letzten Zweitliga-Jahren immer wieder auch erlebt. Dann allerdings zum Negativen, dass eben die Rückrunde auch ein wichtiger Faktor dann ist und da ging es dann meistens eher bergab. Vielleicht geht es ja diesmal dann bergauf.
So wie in der Drittligasaison, da war ja die Rückrunde tatsächlich gut. Vielleicht ist das ja das Tobi Schweinsteiger-Ding. Aber du hast jetzt gerade so völlig nonchalant einen Begriff verwendet. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass einige drüber gestolpert sind. Enkeltauglichkeit. Das musst du bitte erklären. Was ist damit gemeint? Muss man jetzt keinen Router einrichten mehr beim VfL Osnabrück? Man verzichtet auf Technik? Oder was ist mit Enkeltauglichkeit gemeint?
Nein, nein, das bedeutet einfach, dass man versucht, nachhaltig zu sein. Und ja, sozusagen ein Verein zu sein, der eben auch auf seinen grünen Fußsackdruck guckt. Und wie er denn seine Zukunft gestalten will.
Also, ich habe natürlich den erwartbaren Enkelwitz gemacht. Aber da ist ja der VfL –das fand ich interessant, weil das hast du mir nämlich auch in der Vorbereitung zur Sendung geschickt. Und das ist jetzt quasi brandneu. Wir nehmen auf am Mittwoch, dem 25.10. Und du hast da heute erst drüber einen Artikel geschrieben. Es gibt ja viele Vereine, die sagen, wir wollen nachhaltig sein. Wir wollen auf unseren CO2-Fußabdruck gucken und so weiter und so fort. Aber der VfL ist da jetzt aktiv geworden schon seit einer ganzen Zeit. Es gibt eine Gemeinwohlklausel in manchen Verträgen. Magst du uns kurz erklären, was der VfL da macht? Weil das finde ich interessant, weil das könnte ja auch was für andere Vereine sein.
Ja, also erstmal, das ist nicht das erste, wo sie das so versuchen. Es gibt viele Sachen, wo sie eben draufgucken und sich positionieren. Auch sehr stark im Blick zum Beispiel letztes Jahr bei diesem Nachhaltigkeitstag vom DFB, wo man dann gesagt hat, jo, kann man schön machen, aber dann lass doch auch bitte das Flutlicht auf Samstagmittag, wenn es ein heller Tag ist. Da hat sich der VfL schon in den letzten Jahren ziemlich stark positioniert. Diese Gemeinwohlklausel ist jetzt in den neuen Verträgen der Mitarbeiter, also jeder, der neu beim VfL ist oder jetzt eine Gehaltserhöhung bekommt und deswegen einen neuen Vertrag oder irgendwas in dieser Art, der kann also entscheiden, ob er eine Gemeinwohlklausel in seinem Vertrag haben möchte oder nicht. Also das ist ganz wichtig, das beruht auf einer Freiwilligkeit. Und da wird dann, falls er sich dafür entscheidet, bekommt er einen gewissen Betrag mehr an Gehalt. Also das sind bis zu 750 Euro im Jahr. Und der Mitarbeiter kann dann seinen Fußabdruck, seinen CO2-Fußabdruck, also seine CO2-Emission quasi sich errechnen und kann dann einen Teil dieses zusätzlichen Gehalts, was er bekommen hat, in Kompensationszahlungen geben, die dann seine CO2-Emission ausgleichen. Wie gesagt, alles auf einer gewissen Freiwilligkeit. Und man muss auch nicht alles Mögliche angeben. Also wichtig ist, wenn er sich dafür entscheidet, der Arbeitsweg wird auf jeden Fall vom Verein erfasst. Da kommt es dann drauf an, ob er zum Beispiel zu Fuß oder mit dem Auto oder mit Nahverkehr oder wie auch immer zur Arbeitsstelle kommt. Aber alles andere ist halt eben auch freiwillig. Und er kann angeben, zum Beispiel, wie sein Konsum von Fleisch oder Milchprodukten ist, in welchem Haushalt er wohnt, wie der beheizt ist. Und daraus kann man halt eben auf der Seite des Bundesumweltamtes seinen ökologischen Fußabdruck errechnen.
Und dann wird eben auch kooperiert mit einer Organisation, die dann eben hilft, das zu kompensieren. CO2-Zertifikate oder die Kompensation von CO2-Fußabdrücken auch nochmal ein ganz komplexes Thema. Aber das fand ich eben interessant. Nicht nur, weil ich von so einer Klausel bisher noch nicht gehört habe, sondern was ich vor allem spannend fand in dem Artikel, den du geschrieben hast, den werde ich auch verlinken, war eben die Freiwilligkeit dessen. Also das große Vertrauen, dass man da letztlich den Leuten entgegenbringt, dass man sagt, es geht vor allem darum, zu sensibilisieren. Und wenn dann das jemand ganz genau ausrechnen möchte, dann kann er das gerne machen. Wenn aber jemand nur so allgemein angeben, wenn es nur der Arbeitsweg ist, der erfasst wird, dann ist es auch für alle okay. Aber es ist eben einfach mal ein Thema, dass man drüber nachdenkt, was verursache ich hier eigentlich für einen CO2-Ausstoß auch in Zusammenhang mit dem VfL? Ist ja nicht nur der VfL. Das fand ich interessant.
Ja, es geht halt wie gesagt auch immer darum, dieses Bewusstsein zu schärfen, sodass man jetzt nicht sagt, du musst jetzt dann irgendwas bezahlen, wenn du das und das machst, sondern eher diesen Anreiz zu schaffen. Deswegen auch durch dieses etwas mehr an Gehalt. Und dann aber auch dieses Bewusstsein zu schärfen, mit was hinterlasse ich eigentlich diesen Fußabdruck? Also was führt da alles dazu und wo kann ich vielleicht ein bisschen dran schrauben? Und wir haben es ja gesehen, auch bei vielen Spielern in den letzten Jahren, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch bei den Vereinen ist, aber ich weiß, dass häufig auch beim VfL immer wieder das Thema vegane Ernährung, Nachhaltigkeit auch bei den Spielern eine ganz wichtige Rolle spielt. Also wir hatten ja zum Beispiel mit Sven Köhler hatten wir einen Spieler, der da sehr drauf geachtet hat und da sind immer wieder gute Gespräche auch mit den Spielern, mit den Fußballern, die man führt und ich glaube, dass der VfL da auch einen guten Weg geht.
Also ich lausche und staune und überlege, wie es denn wäre, ob es sowas in Hannover auch gibt oder geben könnte und dann denke ich, vielleicht ist auch bald 2030 und dann können wir nochmal drüber sprechen. Nein, so viel habe ich da drüber tatsächlich in Hannover nicht gehört und tatsächlich auch so gute Ansätze und Ideen. Ich glaube, das wäre jetzt etwas, wenn Max einen Podcast darüber machen würde, ich würde absagen, dass er mich groß beteiligen könnte.
Aber du kannst ja zuhören.
Das auf jeden Fall, aber ich wüsste wirklich nicht, was hier in Hannover als Letztes passiert ist, wo ich sagen würde, Mensch, das klingt nach einer richtig grünen Idee und das ist eine richtig gute Idee, Jungs, Mädels, genauso. Von daher schön, dass man das aus Osnabrück hören kann. Ich habe das aus Paderborn in einem anderen Zusammenhang auch mal gehört, dass die dort auch sehr, sehr aktiv sind, was die ganze Geschichte angeht und fand es auch hochgradig spannend. Ich hoffe natürlich, dass auch in Hannover irgendwann der Schalter umgelegt wird. Aber es kostet halt allen voran erstmal Geld. Ich habe vorhin ja schon gesagt, wie das mit den Transfers ist. Das zieht sich natürlich nicht nur im Bereich Transfers durch den Verein.
Vielleicht muss man auch ergänzt sagen, natürlich sehen das nicht immer alle positiv. Der VfL hat dafür jetzt auch einiges an, ich sage mal, Polemik vielleicht auch einstecken müssen. Und an Kritik, Leute, die sagen, was wollt ihr jetzt? Wollt ihr uns umerziehen? Ich erinnere an eine Kolumne in einer anderen Tageszeitung, die das so aufgegriffen haben. Da muss man halt schon immer auch sehr differenzieren.
Wir können alle raten, aus welchem Eck der Presselandschaft diese Kolumne kam. Ich werde es jetzt nicht verraten, weil ihr habt eh alle recht.
Und nicht verlinken.
Wir werden es auch nicht verlinken. Aber das ist ja die Sache. Du kannst die Sache so freiwillig wie möglich machen und so zurückhalten wie möglich. Weil es muss ja niemand mitmachen. Und trotzdem schreien dir Leute in die Kommentare, die wollen uns die Steaks wegnehmen. Oder Uli Höne setzt sich irgendwo hin und sagt, du im ÖZD mir will mir den Zucker verbieten. Wenn wir auf so einer dummen Art und Weise über solche Themen reden, ja sorry, dann wird auch nichts vorangehen können. Aber ist ja schön. Aber deswegen wollte ich es hier eben noch erwähnt haben. Und weil du eben auch gerade heute deinen langen Arbeitstag unter anderem mit diesem Thema verbracht hast.
Ja, stimmt.
Dachte ich, das wollen wir hier unterbringen. Jetzt weiß ich bloß nicht, wie wir vom Thema Enkeltauglichkeit zu Eintracht Braunschweig kommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Anna da eine Brücke sieht.
Nein, das ist der Osnabrücker Spieler, der ein bisschen heißt wie ein Hauptdarsteller beim Bergdoktor. Weil neben Eintracht Braunschweig kenne ich mich sehr gut mit dem Bergdoktor aus. Obfasst würde ich mich lieber über den Bergdoktor unterhalten als über Eintracht Braunschweig. Aber man kann es echt nicht immer aussuchen.
Ja, aber sind die Höhen und Tiefen beim Bergdoktor denn überhaupt vergleichbar mit denen, die Eintracht Braunschweig durchmacht?
Je nachdem, also die Emotionalen auf jeden Fall. Die der Berge wahrscheinlich nicht. Es ist eine Talfahrt. Es ist keine Berge und Talfahrt. Es ist eine Talfahrt, würde ich sagen.
Ist das der Almabtrieb jetzt gerade, der Eintracht? Sagst du uns das, aktuell für alle diejenigen, die es nicht vor Augen haben, letzter Tabellenplatz, 5 Punkte. Also könnte man ja auch sagen, nur 2 Punkte hinter Schalke.
Es ist richtig. Man muss sich da aussuchen, an wem man sich messen lassen möchte. Und gerne lasse ich mich an Schalke 04 messen. Ja, nee, es läuft irgendwie nicht so gut. Also tatsächlich auch bei 5 Punkten ist völlig klar, es können nicht 2 Siege sein. Es ist immerhin einer. Wir haben einmal gewonnen, und zwar gegen Schalke 04. Ja, das war wunderschön. Diese Saison ist die Hinrunde, Mitte der Hinrunde. Und wir haben schon zweimal gegen Schalke 04 gespielt, nämlich einmal im Pokal, da haben wir verloren. Und dann direkt danach, also innerhalb von einer Woche, haben wir zweimal gegen Schalke 04 gespielt, ein Spiel haben wir verloren. Deswegen keine zweite Pokalrunde nächste Woche für uns. Das Ligaspiel haben wir dann tatsächlich gewonnen. Das war schön, ja.
Ich glaube, das ist auch gerade so die statistische Verteilung, wenn du zweimal gegen Schalke spielst, dass du einmal verlierst und einmal... Wahrscheinlich. Aber woran liegt denn das, dass Eintracht Braunschweig sich so schwer tut in dieser Saison? Also so komplett verwundert einen das ja nicht, dass Eintracht da im unteren Drittel der Tabelle abhängt. Da wollen wir jetzt ja nicht irgendwie so tun, als ob das abnormal wäre. Aber es war ja schon sehr früh sehr viel Unmut zu hören. Und wir haben ja auch einen Trainerwechsel schon hier.
Beziehungsweise, ich würde fast über zwei Trainerwechsel sprechen wollen. Nämlich einmal den vor der Saison, weil Michael Schiele, der sehr, also natürlich nicht komplett unumstritten war, weil sportlich lief es durchwachsen. Aber immerhin hat man dann am Ende die Klasse gehalten. Mit welcher Schützenhilfe auch immer. Aber wir spielen 2. Liga und haben die Klasse direkt halten können, ohne Relegation oder so, mit viel Zittern aber direkt. Und dann ist Michael Schiele entlassen worden. Sportlich kann man das sicherlich argumentieren, auch wenn man vor der Saison gesagt hat, wir steigen auf jeden Fall direkt ab oder können uns vielleicht in die Relegation rennen. Das ist dann nicht eingetreten und er ist trotzdem entlassen worden, nachdem er im Januar bis 2025 eine Vertragsverlängerung bekommen hat.
Muss man das verstehen? Also du sagst es jetzt so nonchalant weg, aber …Überhaupt nicht, gar nicht.
Nee, das sind auch alles …Also irgendwie beantwortet all das so ein bisschen deine Frage, was unsere Probleme sind, nämlich alles. Tobi hat mich neulich gefragt, wo ist eigentlich euer Geld? Und ich habe gesagt, ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, alle sagen, wir haben kein Geld. Aber wo ist es? Keiner weiß es. Genau, also wir haben den Trainer entlassen. Das hat im Umfeld für sehr viel Unmut gesorgt, weil alles in allem war Michael Schiele beliebt, war zwei Jahre im Amt, ist mit uns aufgestiegen, hat die Klasse gehalten, war irgendwie ein guter Typ. Kleiner süddeutscher Sympath, darauf stehen wir irgendwie. Alles in einem, Grüße nach Darmstadt an der Stelle. Und dann holt man Jens Härtel und kündigt den an, als die Person, die das jetzt irgendwie fortführen soll oder maßgeblich Veränderungen anstoßen soll, steht aber tatsächlich in seiner Philosophie für den gleichen tendenziell defensiven, tendenziell destruktiven Fußball, wie Michael Schiele das auch tat. Also da ist jetzt sportlich irgendwie nichts Revolutionäres passiert, bis auf das man eben den Trainer entlassen hat. Warum hat sich niemandem bisher so richtig erschlossen? Der sportlichen Leitung offensichtlich auch nicht, weil sonst hätte man den Trainer vor einer Woche nicht schon wieder entlassen. Tatsächlich eine sehr kurze Trainerstation für Jens Härtel, der eigentlich wirklich relevant lange immer im Amt gewesen ist. Bei Magdeburg unter anderem und Rostock. Ein sympathischer Typ, der, glaube ich, sich auch zwischendurch wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen gefragt hat, was das hier soll. Ja, genau. Und genau, jetzt haben wir Mark Pfitzner als Trainer. Der darf zwei Spiele, also jetzt gegen Düsseldorf, Freitagabend auf der Bank sitzen und dann das Double betreuen. Nächsten Sonntag. Das wird sehr aufregend, weil Mark Pfitzner unfassbarer Braunschweiger ist. Der war nur drei Jahre ein bisschen in Bremen als Co-Trainer. Und sonst war der nur in Braunschweig. Er hat sogar Bundesliga gespielt und alles ist da geboren und groß geworden. Und jetzt ist er Trainer im Derby. Wenn das keine Geschichte ist. Solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußball.
Das heißt, er übernimmt das Gepöbel von Fezic? Oder wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Ich weiß es noch nicht so genau. Na ja, genau. Es ist alles ein großer Chaoshaufen, der betromt und betreut wird von Vollmann, unserem Sportdirektor, der, glaube ich, als Einziger weiß, was er da tut.
Aber Pfitzner ist jetzt nur für diese zwei Spiele.
Ja, er ist kein Fußballlehrer. Also er hat einen Trainerschein. Aber hat halt nicht einen Fußballlehrer gemacht, und deswegen müsste man Strafen zahlen. Das Lustige ist, es gibt zwei Personen in diesem Verein, die einen Fußballlehrerschein haben. Der eine ist Jonas Stefan, der macht irgendwas im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum, glaube ich. Der andere ist Peter Vollmann. Und jetzt ist natürlich große Aufregung, weil nicht ganz auszuschließen ist, dass damit Marc Pfitzner Trainer bleiben kann, Peter Vollmann sich selbst ins Traineramt hebt. Damit halt diese Regel bestehen kann. Das ist großartig.
Da muss er auch nicht mehr so kritisch mit dem Trainer sein.
Nein.
Wie in einer guten Folge des Bergdoktors.
Sehr gut.
Da möchte Susanne direkt reinkrätschen.
Beim Bergdoktor bin ich wirklich raus. Aber ich wollte einfach nur mal fragen, wie schätzt du denn diese Chancen überhaupt ein und was würdest du dir denn für einen Trainer wünschen? Max, wenn ich da mal so einhaken darf und dir die Frage wegnehmen.
Ich würde mir einen Trainer wünschen, der zum Kader passt. Das ist, glaube ich, tatsächlich wesentlicher Punkt unseres beständigen Misserfolgs, dass wir einen Kader haben, der nicht auf defensive Stabilität ausgerichtet ist, sondern angewiesen ist, auf viel Kreativität im Mittelfeld, um Stürmer zu bedienen, so sie denn gesund sind und da. Ja, das ist jetzt alles Polemik, weil ich unfassbar frustriert bin seit 18 Monaten, deswegen seht es mir bitte nach. Ich würde mir einen Trainer wünschen, der Bock auf den Verein hat. Ich würde tatsächlich Motivation und Lust auf einen eher skurrilen Verein mit sehr, sehr schwierigen Jahren über Spielphilosophie stellen wollen. Weil der Verein befindet sich nicht in einem besonders guten Zustand. Es wird immer wieder erwähnt, dass es wenig Geld gibt. Und ich frage mich auch wirklich, warum. Weil es ist jetzt das zweite Jahr in der 2. Liga. Wir hatten wirtschaftlich eigentlich sogar ganz gescheite Abgänge. Immanuel Ferrell ist von uns zum HSV gewechselt für 750.000 Euro. Das heißt, ja, da irgendwas knirscht und hakt. Das ist schon eine ganze Weile. Und du brauchst eine Person, die dem gewachsen ist. Das ist jetzt vielleicht sehr kitschig, aber vielleicht ist es tatsächlich Mark Pfitzner. Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, weil der hat ja noch nie trainiert. Der war ja immer nur Co-Trainer. Ich kann das nicht bewerten. Deswegen kann ich auch gar nicht sagen, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was da jetzt am Freitag passieren wird. Es wird geschrieben in der Braunschweiger Zeitung, dass die Mannschaft in den Trainingseinheiten so wirkt, als hätte sie endlich wieder Lust darauf, Fußball zu spielen. Und endlich wird wieder gelacht. Und endlich haben die Leute irgendwie, so auf dem Niveau spielt sich das da gerade ab. Und auf dem Niveau würde ich auch deine Frage beantworten wollen. Hauptsache, der hat irgendwie Lust darauf, da wieder was entstehen zu lassen. Das Gefühl hatte ich und hatten sehr viele andere bei Michael Schiele. Diesen Funken hatte ich bei Jens Härtel irgendwie nicht. Das ist natürlich auch eine Unterstellung, weiß ich nicht genau. Und deswegen finde ich es immer noch schade, dass man diese Zusammenarbeit nicht fortgesetzt hat.
Das ist übrigens etwas, was, glaube ich, den VfL auch letzte Saison stark gemacht hat. Und auch diese Saison immer noch so ist, dass das Schweinsteiger dieses verkörpert, dass er so Bock auf diesen Verein hat und dass er auch nicht irgendwie über irgendwelche Trainingsbedingungen schimpft und dass es da am Trainingszentrum irgendwie blöd ist. Und dass sie dann vielleicht zu dem Platz immer da hinfahren müssen. Der ist zwar gut, aber dann immer diese Fahrt usw. Sondern dann setzt er sich da irgendwie in Bulli und sagt, so Leute, wir fahren da jetzt rüber und wir machen das und nimmt irgendwie alle mit. Und das ist wirklich eine Geschichte, wo man sagen muss, dass er das halt geschafft hat. Und das ist, glaube ich, wirklich, was du gerade erzählt hast, wirklich wichtig, dass man so dieses Gefühl von dem Trainer hat, der das auf die Mannschaft auch überträgt.
Und gleichzeitig hast du aber auch schon, Anna, mit dem Abgang von Feray ja vielleicht auch einen Hinweis darauf gegeben, warum es eben mit der Kreativität in dieser Saison noch nicht so weit her ist. Du hast gesagt, der Trainer sollte eben zu diesem Kader passen. Wer ist denn im Kader noch da, der solche Dinge tun kann wie eben Feray, also eben offensiv mal eine Idee haben?
Na ja, wir haben eigentlich ein ganz spannendes Mittelfeld mit Janis Nicolaou, das ist unser Kapitän, und Danilo Wiebe. Und das sind auch Punkte, also dahin führt mich Danilo Wiebe, die jetzt in den letzten Spielen so ein paar Fragen aufgeworfen haben, weil der eigentlich also ins Mittelfeld gehört, aber in der rechten Ausauf, der rechte aus dem Verteidiger Position gespielt hat und niemand so richtig wusste warum. Also viele Spieler auf Positionen gespielt haben, auf die sie nominell eigentlich nicht gehören und so was kann mal funktionieren oder aus der Not geboren heraus nachvollziehbar sein, war es jetzt aber zuletzt eher eigentlich nicht. Und ich glaube, wenn du dieses tendenziell schon vielversprechende Mittelfeld zusammenwachsen lässt und zusammen spielen lässt, dass das zum einen für Stabilität sorgen könnte, weil du vor drei Stunden zum Beispiel auch einen Innenverteidiger geholt hast, der vielleicht die Viererkette sortieren könnte mit Ermin Bikakcic, der vereinslos war, nachdem er ein paar Jahre in Hoffenheim gespielt hat. Also auch hier ein kleiner Hoffnungsschimmer in Richtung Kader, der geschwächt aus dem Sommer kam, nach den Abgängen von Feray, Demedina und Benkovic. Wenn man den Blick in Richtung offensive Mittelfeld bzw. offensive richtet, liegen so ein paar Hoffnungen in Florian Krüger, der zu uns kam. Da wurde auch kolportiert, dass Hannover 96 an dem interessiert gewesen sei. Das ist eine qualitativ erstaunlich hohe Range. Ich hoffe, dass er noch mehr zur Form findet. Er ist jetzt ganz neu im Kader. Er braucht vielleicht seine Zeit, um sich da zurechtzufinden. Robin Krause ist ein absolut wichtiger Akteur. Durch sein Auftreten, seine Emotionen, sein immer wieder reinarbeiten und reinkämpfen, genauso wie Fabio Kaufmann, der vielleicht nicht immer das glücklichste Füßchen hat auf der einen Seite, aber der beständig wütend ist über diese furchtbare Situation, in der sich der Eintracht befindet. Das schätze ich sehr, weil ich glaube, dass vielen von uns die Energie fehlt, diese Wut irgendwie aufrechtzuerhalten, dass sie aber wichtig ist, um sich da unten rauszuarbeiten. Was halt einfach fehlt, ist ein Stürmer, den haben wir. Der ist Anthony Uccia, der hat sich verletzt im Spiel gegen Nürnberg. Das war unser einziges kleines Hoch. Wir haben gegen Schalke gewonnen, dann zwei Unentschieden, beim zweiten Unentschieden, das war das 2-2-2 gegen Nürnberg, hat er sich die Schulter verletzt und seitdem haben wir nur noch verloren.
Und wie ist jetzt der Ausblick für Braunschweig? Es ist alles wie immer kompliziert, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt. Die nächsten beiden Spiele jetzt Fortuna und dann dieses kleine Spielchen gegen Hannover. Da wird man sich ja jetzt noch nicht mit befassen. Jetzt geht der volle Fokus auf Fortuna Düsseldorf. Das merkt man auch dieser Runde hier. Da hat man das von Anfang an gemerkt, dass das wirklich unwichtig ist. Sechs Tore hat Braunschweig erst erzielt. Nur Wien-Wiesbaden hat mit neun Toren noch eine einstellige Anzahl. Alle anderen haben schon deutlich mehr Treffer erzielt. Aber Anschluss ist ja da. Und wenn ich mich an die letzte Saison erinnere, da war es zwar so, dass man eher das Abrutschen verhindern musste, aber da war es doch auch so, dass zwischenzeitlich Braunschweig mal zumindest auf dem Relegationsplatz war. Und man hat es ja dann immer wieder geschafft, wenn auch mit anderem Trainer und so weiter und so fort. Hast du ja alles schon erklärt. Ist das jetzt vielleicht auch nur gerade eine hoffnungslose Momentaufnahme?
Ich wünschte, ich könnte Ja sagen.
Es geht ja nicht über die Lippen, man hat gemerkt, wie du kennst.
Es geht mir nicht so richtig über die Lippen, muss ich sagen. Ich kann halt wirklich überhaupt nicht einschätzen, was jetzt passiert. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, welcher Trainer geholt wird. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass irgendwie noch Gelder aufgetan worden sind, weil sonst holst du auch einen Ermin nicht einfach so oder nochmal zurück. Also der spielt ja auch nicht umsonst. So Herzensangelegenheit, die Stars, alles schön und gut. Ich finde einfach, dass dieser Sportdirektor wirklich nicht mehr da sein sollte, um einfach langfristig meine Idee zu entwickeln. Weil lieber steige ich mit einer langfristigen Idee ab, als dieses langsame Sterben Jahr für Jahr zu ertragen. Es ist wirklich, wirklich schwierig. Was gibt uns Hoffnung? Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Also es hängt wirklich total von dem ab, was jetzt passieren wird. Weil unter Jens Herpel, hatte ich gesagt, da ist keine Entwicklung in den letzten drei Monaten passiert. Unser bester Spieler steht im Tor. Unser zweitbester Spieler ist bis Weihnachten krank. Ja, und jetzt mal gucken. Also ab und zu gibt es Spiele, in denen erstaunlich viel funktioniert, in denen es auch spielerisch absolut ansehnlich ist. Irgendwie sehr attraktives Kurzpass-Spiel. Viel funktioniert, nur die Tore nicht fallen. Und wenn jetzt diese berühmt-berüchtigte Spielfreude vielleicht wirklich wieder Einzug erhält und die jungen Spieler Selbstbewusstsein gewinnen und sich noch mehr an diese Körperlichkeit in der 2. Liga gewöhnen.
Ich muss sagen, ehrlich gesagt, ich kannte schon deine Meinung und du warst ja auch zuletzt im Rasenfunk, hast ja auch kein Blatt vorm Mund genommen. Aber der Begriff langsames Sterben, der hat mich jetzt schon ein bisschen unvorbereitet getroffen, muss ich sagen. Weil ist nicht eigentlich Braunschweig jetzt die letzten zehn Jahre da, also immer am selben Ort, nämlich irgendwo zwischen 2. und 3. Liga? Und natürlich fühlt sich das anders an, wenn man so eine Saison erlebt und das zwischendurch dann auch in der 3. Liga mal nicht so gut aussieht. Aber dann schafft man den Aufstieg usw. usf. Aber eigentlich hat sich doch da so allein von der Tabellensituation hier gar nicht so viel verändert. Ich gucke, der Aufstieg aus der Regionalliga war 2007, 2008, seitdem immer 3. oder 2. Liga.
Ja, ich glaube, diese 10 Lieberknechtjahre, das hat uns einfach, das hängt uns immer noch so ein bisschen nach, weil das einfach so die große Liebe ist, an die seitdem nichts mehr rangekommen ist. Du denkst aber, es ist halt so, wir tindern halt im Moment, aber es funktioniert nicht. Wir haben immer noch so ein bisschen Liebeskummer. Klar, es ging auch schon wesentlich schlechter. Wir sind halt wirklich fast in die Regionalliga abgestiegen. Das war einfach unfassbar knapp am letzten Spieltag mit irgendwie einem Torunterschied gerade so die Klasse gehalten, in der dritten Liga. Insofern ist es verhältnismäßig okay. Und du merkst ja den Braunschweigern so einen gewissen Pragmatismus an. Also du gehst halt hin und steigst ab. Und es findet klar, wir sind alle genervt und wir hätten es gerne alle anders. Aber so richtig schlimm findet es glaube ich inzwischen noch keiner mehr. Weil es halt die Eintracht. Aber was mir halt fehlt, ist die Idee. Also das, was Susanne gerade erzählte, wofür steht der Verein. Was ist die langfristige Idee, auch davon abgesehen, dass man sagt, man will die Klasse halten. Und da fällt mir leider im Moment nicht so richtig viel zu ein. Und das tut schon ein bisschen weh. Und das ist das, von dem ich halt gehofft habe, dass es vielleicht unter Schiele wieder wachsen kann, dass du halt an Eintracht Braunschweig und an irgendwas denkst. Und das stellt sich halt irgendwie nicht ein.
Aber immerhin wissen wir jetzt, wie die Bergdoktor-Folge zu Eintracht Braunschweig heißen würde. Tinder gegen Lieberknechtkummer. Komm, ich nenne die ganze Folge so. Ihr drei, das war sehr, sehr interessant, amüsant und zum Teil richtig emotional. Das hätte ich gar nicht erwartet zu dieser späten Stunde. Es hat unheimlich Spaß gemacht, mit euch dreien auf eure Vereine zu blicken. Und jedes Einzelsegment hätte hier noch eine Stunde länger gehen können. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank euch drei. Danke Anna Lautenbach. Ich drücke dir die Daumen, dass du wenig Liebeskummer mit Eintracht Braunschweig in den Neck vertragen musst.
Danke Susanne und natürlich danke Tobi.
Ja, dann müssen wir jetzt auch als Nächsten Tobi danken, dem, der sich schon in zwei Wochen so auf dieses Derby freut. Ich bin so gespannt. Ich meine, ihr wisst es ja noch viel besser als ich, aber es sind schon so viele lustige Dinge passiert, auch unerwartete Dinge rund um diese Derbys. Aber erstmal danke dir Tobi, dass du hier mit dabei warst und mit deiner Podcast-Stimme auch hier im Rasenfunk vertreten warst.
Danke für die Einladung. Danke euch drei. Ich hoffe, ich konnte die Stimmung so ein bisschen nach oben treiben mit meiner zwar neuen und irgendwie noch ungewohnten Euphorie, aber zumindest mit guter Laune, was den Blick auf die Tabelle angeht.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass ich dich mal als gute Laune-Onkel zu irgendeiner Sendung einlade. Aber hey, ich meine, wir sind jetzt im zehnten Jahr. Irgendwann musste das auch mal passieren.
Es muss sich auch was ändern.
Und ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank. Es war ein fantastisches Debüt. Susanne Vetter, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Und natürlich allen noch mal empfohlen. Brückengeflüster, da kann man dich viel ausführlicher noch holen. Danke dir, liebe Susanne.
Jetzt habe ich mich nochmal verhaspelt zum Schluss. Euch auch noch einen schönen Abend. Danke für die Einladung, Max, für das Debüt. Ich wollte nur sagen, das Derby steht an, aber Anna danach spielt dann der VfL in Braunschweig. Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja dann mal live vor Ort.
Das hängt vom Derby und von Tobis Trinkkräfte.
Anna, der November ist wirklich in Hannover, zu Hause gegen Osnabrück und dann beim HSV. Das ist November, wie er im Buche steht.
Ich möchte nicht darüber sprechen. Ich freue mich auf die nächste Bergdoktor-Staffel.
Das kann man sehr gut verstehen. Für alle diejenigen, die das jetzt nicht bei YouTube gesehen haben, die Motivation, an die Bremer Brücke zu fahren, sprang Anna förmlich aus den Augen. Also wirklich alles an ihr schrie, ja, da habe ich Bock drauf.
Erst in Braunschweig. Bremer Brücke ist in der Rückrunde.
Mensch, da gibt es ja nicht mal einen Grund, sich das anzugucken. Aber hey, ich habe gehört, auswärts kann Osnabrück nichts, Anna. Also hab Hoffnung.
Wir sprechen uns danach oder davor.
Genau, und bevor das jetzt hier in der Therapiesitzung ausartet, danke ich euch dreien nochmal. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da draußen ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Empfehlt diese Folge bitte weiter. Sagt anderen, dass es dieses Ligaturformat gibt. Ihr wisst ja, wir sprechen über die Europäischen Ligen hier, über die zweite Liga. Und das eine oder andere wird auch in den nächsten Wochen hier noch so noch mit reinkommen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke für euren Support. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubundkiosk.rasenfunk.de sind die wichtigen URLs dafür. Und ansonsten schaut auf rasenfunk.de, was es sonst noch so gibt bei uns. Macht's gut, bis bald.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr KNAUSA.